MARCUS SMITH: My
name is Marcus Smith.
ERIK RAHTJEN: And
I'm Erik Rahtjen.
MARCUS SMITH: And we are
both the software developers
at Stable Kernel, which is a
mobile consultancy in Atlanta.
We've both done full stat
Dart applications for clients
that we've got live now.
For the web, we're
using AngularDart,
which you're all familiar with.
For the back end,
we're using Aqueduct,
which is a back end framework
that we've developed for Dart.
It's HTTP multithreaded
object-oriented.
We've got our own ORM.
It's got built-in
OAuth 2 and [INAUDIBLE]
runs just kind of
Dart VM on the server.
We're here today to kind
of go over briefly how
we are deploying
these full stack Dart
applications on Google Cloud
using Docker and Kubernetes.
So Docker, if you're
not familiar with it,
is a containerization service.
It's a lightweight way of
packaging up your code and all
of its dependencies in a way
that can be consistently run
on any kind of machine.
So you don't need to worry if
it's Linux, or Windows, or Mac,
or anything else.
And to build your application
into a Docker image,
you just use a Docker file.
And this is extremely easy
for both Angular and Aqueduct
applications, because
Google provides a base Dart
image, which for Angular, you
can use as a build environment.
And then we tend to run ours
in an Nginx Docker image
after that.
And Aqueduct is able to just
use the Dart base image.
And all of this is fairly
boilerplate to where
we tend to use the same
one for every project
with maybe just a
minor tweak or so.
And then Erik is going to
tell you about Kubernetes.
ERIK RAHTJEN: So Kubernetes
is a container orchestration
service.
It basically takes your
applications in Docker images
and deploys them
out onto a series
of nodes called a cluster.
It Manages the deployment rules.
So say, if you didn't ever
want a container of yours
to be using more
than 50% CPU, it
would go ahead and
launch another one.
Or if it needed to
provision a new node,
it could go ahead
and handle that, too.
Additionally, it handles
internal networking
between your applications.
So it'll go ahead and
set up all the routing
between those for you.
And it also handles all
external communications as well.
MARCUS SMITH: I think--
ERIK RAHTJEN: So--
MARCUS SMITH: I'll take it.
ERIK RAHTJEN: All right.
MARCUS SMITH: I think the most
appealing thing for me about
Kubernetes is you're just
defining the rules for how
you want your deployment to be.
So in programming terms, it'd
be all declarative instead
of imperative.
You just tell it, here's how
I want my deployment to be.
I want it to have three Aqueduct
servers running, or no more
than five, no less than three.
And here's the parameters
I want it to run in.
And it manages all the hard
parts of getting them set up
and getting the right state.
And what this really
boils down to is
you get to spend more time
developing your applications
and less time doing
DevOps, while still
getting all the benefits of
professional DevOps engineers
who put together Kubernetes,
and Google Cloud,
and whatever else.
ERIK RAHTJEN: One of the
great things about Kubernetes
is it's open source.
It's already super
robust, so it's
easy to define a lot
of complex rules.
But if it doesn't
meet your demands,
you can go ahead and
extend it yourself.
It is usable by any
cloud provider, not just
Google Cloud.
But I don't know why you'd be
a traitor, especially when it
works out so well
with Google Cloud.
So one of the things that
that enables you to do
is it's consistent across
any of these providers
or across your own bare metal.
So maybe Google Cloud doesn't
provide a database server
that has 10,000 gigs
of RAM, or whatever,
and you want to use that.
You can go ahead and do that,
and Kubernetes can manage
doing those types of things.
It's self-healing,
which is really neat.
So if your applications
crash, it's
going to go ahead and
relaunch the application.
And additionally, it can kind
of take different applications
and figure out, can a node
have eight of them running?
Is it capable of doing that?
OK.
I'll pack eight onto that one.
Or maybe this node
can only have four.
So it can figure all
that out for you.
It handles SSL
certificates as well,
and TLS termination using
native load balancers
to the cloud providers.
MARCUS SMITH: So we know it's
kind of a lot to really cover
in depth in a five-minute talk.
But on our blog at
stablekernel.com/blog,
we've kind of got some
walkthroughs on setting up
Kubernetes and running all
the way through Google Cloud.
We've got documentation
up for Aqueduct as well.
ERIK RAHTJEN: Yep.
MARCUS SMITH: And
then we're also--
if you want to develop Dart
full time, we are hiring.
So end on the good news.
ERIK RAHTJEN: Yep.
[APPLAUSE]